[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bush
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu cette vidéo elle en est à
presque 600 milles vue sur les réseaux
sociaux
pourquoi est ce que vous savez pourquoi
quand on cherchait la supprimer elle
continue quand même de circuler parce
que c'est super jean parce que c'est la
femme qui valait trois milliards
parce que c'est la femme bionique
hashtag neurosciences hashtag
transhumanisme hashtag intelligence
artificielle hashtag nouvelles
technologies parce que le regard des
gens change
vous ne voyez plus là une femme
handicapée but il est invalide amputé
non vous voyez une femme bionique une
femme mi humaine mi robot une femme qui
s'inscrit dans le futur une femme avant
gardiste une femme une vraie quoi et
bien cette femme c'est moi enfin c'est
comme ça en tout cas qu'on voit et qu'on
qualifie maintenant sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est fou depuis que cette aventure
technologique a commencé tout le monde
s'excite la veille de mon opération en
novembre 2018
pendant la conférence de presse presque
toutes les chaînes nationales étaient
représentés des amis qui n'avaient plus
fait signe depuis une dizaine d'années
murray intègrent dans leurs cercles et
même me félicite publiquement sur
internet mais est-ce qu'on est vu comme
un individu ou comme un phénomène
pourquoi cet engouement qu'est ce que le
progrès réveille chez chacun d'entre
nous
il ya 14 ans vous faisiez quoi vous en
souvenez pas et moi il ya 14 ans qu'est
ce que je faisais vous avez envie de
savoir ça se voit et bien j'étais sur un
lit d'hôpital
alors si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je
serai une pionnière
une première de cordée je vous aurais
répondu on n'en mais vous plaisantez
c'est juste impossible maintenant
imaginez que vous avez un super pouvoir
que vous êtes comme super jaimie où
steve austin des années 80 c'est à dire
que vous faites des choses dont les
autres sont encore incapables
comme lorsque vous avez réussi à tenir
pour la première fois sur un vélo a
regardé inspecteur derrick sans vous
endormir pourtant vous restez wonder
woman spider man super jaimie aussi en
dehors de leurs exploits ils ont comme
nous un passé une enfance dans une
histoire sentimentale comme nous ils ont
vécu des moments géniaux mais comme nous
ils ont aussi vécu des moments plus
difficiles comme perdre un parent ou un
ami être licencié injustement de son
travail être quittées par la personne
qu'on rêve connaît toutes sortes de
rupture des soucis financiers
une maladie une dépression avec le
sentiment d'être un poids je suis pas là
pour vous saper le moral pour faire
pleurer dans les chaumières
bien au contraire la preuve vivante et
devant vous et ce n'est pas un cas
unique
il en existe beaucoup mais alors qu'est
ce qui fait la différence
et bien la différence comme pour chacun
c'est le parcours imaginé encore
imaginez vous vous réveillez un jour sur
un lit d'hôpital
vous n'avez plus de jambes plus bras
droit et vous n'avez même pas trente
deux ans
eh bien c'est ce qui m'est arrivé alors
là vous n'avez pas le choix si vous
voulez continuer à vivre du mieux
possible quelle que soit l'épreuve de
retomber sur soi de poser une pierre
après l'autre de ne rien lâcher de
toujours y croire sans savoir où ça va
vous mener de progresser le progrès
c'est quoi c'est aller de l'avant
avancez et bien je vais vous faire une
confidence
cet accident a même déclenché chez moi
un vrai changement intérieur celui de
conquérir ma vie et non plus la subir
j'ai donc décidé dans cette nouvelle vie
de réaliser tous les rêves que je
m'étais interdit jusqu'à présent et
notamment celui de devenir artiste
peintre professionnelle
j'ai donc pas du matin au soir j'ai
commencé à exposer dans des galeries des
salons des festivals en france et puis à
l'étranger new york berlin
un cameroun danemark italie belgique
suisse irlande
aujourd'hui je vis de mon art et
j'expose dans les salons d'art
contemporain qui draine environ trente
mille personnes en trois jours
de la même manière j'ai appris à vivre
avec mon handicap à accepter la lenteur
la persévérance le fait de tout prévoir
à l avance par exemple à moins de
sorties s'organise si je prends mon
fauteuil électrique est ce que j'aurai à
cette batterie et puis aussi apprendre à
se sentir bien dans sa peau posé pour
des photographes pour recevoir plus
comme une vénus de milo que comme une
femme handicapée et puis aussi faire du
sport la natation en compétition
et puis d'autres sports que je préside
pratique aujourd'hui en quasi autonomie
comme le ski l'équitation la plongée et
puis tout au long de ce parcours j'ai
pas arrêté de faire des rencontres
extraordinaires qui m'ont à chaque fois
mené de projet en projet aujourd'hui en
dehors d'être une artiste je suis une
mère de famille comblée et une femme
engagée avec mon mari dans le handicap
et l'humanitaire je suis juste à ma
place et je fourmille de projets
auxquels je donne du sens après avoir
progressé pas-à-pas step by step
je suis aujourd'hui debout devant vous
et je me suis jamais senti aussi entière
alors eh bien alors la conclusion je
dirais chuter ce n'est pas le plus
important ce qui compte c'est se relever
et c'est possible pour chacun d'entre
nous et c'est ça qui fait les plus
grands les héros ensuite l'importance du
parcours du chemin de sentir qu'on va
vers le mieux qu'on va de l'avant pour
soi mais aussi avec les autres
peu importe d'où on vient quels sont vos
objectifs
le challenge qui vous tiennent à coeur
qui sont votre moteur c'est ça le
progrès parce que le progrès c'est aussi
le révélateur du potentiel humain
vous allez voir le 21 novembre 2018
dernier je me suis fait opérer selon la
technologie tmr pour être la première
française à bénéficier d'une prothèse de
bras bionique commandé par le cerveau il
s'agit de reconnecter des nerfs qui ont
été sectionnés dans le bras au moment de
l'amputation mais qui sont restées
intactes
qui servait à ouvrir la main ferme et la
main faire une rotation du poignet
fléchir étendre le coude et à les
reconnecter à des muscles du bras des
pectoraux des dorsaux en fonction du
type d'amputation de bras l'avantagé de
cette technologie par rapport à une un
système de prothèse myoélectrique
classique et d'avoir plus de signaux
jusqu'à 6 au lieu de 2 qui commande la
prothèse de plus en fait les nerfs ont
été reconnectés sur un schéma logique et
donc ils retrouvent leurs fonctions
motrices initial par exemple le nerf qui
permettait d'ouvrir la main va permettre
d'ouvrir la main la prothèse la commande
de la prothèse et donc intuitive le
patient à dacca pensée en tête aux
mouvements pour que la prothèse
l'exécutent de de la même manière en
fait avec ce système on peut imaginer
faire des mouvements simultanés comme
par exemple levé le coude et attraper un
verre dans le placard dans un même
mouvement
donc on gagne donc en rapidité en
fluidité et c'est beaucoup moins
fatigant fini de repeindre la cuisine
envers poireau parce que le petit pot
pour bébé vous a échappé la prothèse
maintenant avec ce système on peut
imaginer retrouver un vrai travail mêmes
manuels parce que finalement on n'est
pas plus lent que les autres et ça ça
représente une vraie avancée dans
l'intégration de la personne handicapée
dans la société
alors justement qu'est ce qui va me
permettre cette prothèse alors cette
prothèse va me permettre de retrouver
mes pouvoirs d'avant et notamment celui
en tant qu'artiste peintre de repeint de
la main droite parce que évidemment
j'étais droitière de marché en tenant la
can avec ma main avec la prothèse ce qui
va me permettre en fait de donner la
main ma fille de 7 ans ou de lui porter
son cartable de soulager ma main gauche
qui fait tout depuis 14 ans et qui
commence à voir des sérieux problèmes de
canal carpien parce que le handicap
c'est une chose mais vieillir avec le
handicap c'en est une autre
dans les vernissages de pouvoir prendre
un verre et un petit four sans devoir
choisir l'un ou l'autre de faire
d'autres sports handisport qui
nécessitent l'usagé de deux bras
d'arrêter de prendre mes dents comme une
entreprise plus plein d'autres choses
auxquelles je n'ai pas encore pensé
en tout cas c'est clair cette avancée
technologique va m'ouvrir des nouveaux
horizons elle arrive dans le
prolongement d'un parcours et c'est une
avancée exceptionnelle
mais attention c'est pas magique c'est
un progrès qui demande de ne jamais
abandonner comme tout le reste et qui
demande beaucoup de patience
d'entraînement de persévérance de
courage parce que non seulement en fait
il faut maîtriser chacun des six
mouvements de base mais ensuite il faut
arriver à les enchaîner tout en se
relâchant entre chaque contraction pour
progressivement intégré la prothèse de
bras aux gestes de la vie quotidienne
comme si c'était son propre bras et ça
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué mais bon
ce qui est sûr c'est que au bout de deux
ans de rééducation intensive avec mon
ergothérapeute jeu pourrait commander
cette prothèse de bras par la pensée en
attendant oui la route est longue quand
il s'agit de répéter 30 fois de suite le
même mouvement ou de déplacer 40 fois de
suite un objet d'une étagère à une autre
c'est c'est comme un sportif de haut
niveau en fait qui suit un entraînement
il faut s'entraîner s'entraîner pour
faire des micro progrès qui un jour
donneront un grand résultat
c'est pas facile d'être une super
héroïne ça s'apprend avec des phases de
progression de stagnation de progression
mais le progrès c'est aussi d'avoir
conscience de tout ça ce qui est
formidable dans cette aventure c'est que
c'est un travail d'équipé
comme c'est une première française
chaque membre de l'équipe chirurgien
ergothérapeute prothésiste médecin
physique et réadaptation progresse avec
6 motivation ses tâtonnements ses doutes
ses succès ils essayent ils testent il
avance sans jamais perdre de vue leur
objectif
en fait on forme une équipe où chacun a
une patience de fou étape par étape où
chacun avec ses ressources apporte sa
pierre et son moral à l'édifice on est
humain mais personne ne lâche personne
ne tombe et s'il ya un découragement qui
arrive on se relève parce qu'on
travaille tous au progrès
on est conscient que beaucoup de gens à
nous suivre via les réseaux sociaux et
via les médias beaucoup du corps médical
mais aussi un certain nombre de patient
amputé le bras qui espèrent beaucoup de
cette technologie qui suivent mes
progrès jour après jour et dont un
certain nombre sont déjà inscrits sur la
liste pour se faire opérer
en fait je suis consciente que
j'appartiens à une histoire collective
je suis responsable de moi mais aussi de
ceux qui espèrent et de ceux qui
oeuvrent je porte une mission je
m'inscris dans la société de demain
je m'inscris dans le mouvement parce que
je suis nous ne sommes qu'un maillon de
la chaîne et je crois que c'est ça en
fait qui est fabuleux c'est finalement
nous sommes tous les maillons d'une
formidable chaîne humaine où chacun
oeuvre pour le prochain où chacun
apporte sa pierre pour que le suivant
apporte une pierre encore plus solide et
ainsi travailler de génération en
génération vers le progrès qui
transcende notre existence personnelle
pour moi c'est vraiment ça le sens de
l'existence et c'est peut-être ça
finalement qui explique le succès de la
vidéo que je vous ai montré au tout
début et vous est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être entouré de gens avec
qui vous avez les mêmes aspirations avec
qui vous avez envie de de partage et de
transmettre de d'améliorer la vie des
autres de changer le monde
est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi le progrès
merci
[Applaudissements]